comme vous le savez tf avait coutume de
diffuser le samedi soir l'excellente
émission de nicolas hulot ushuaïa
mais désormais tf1 diffuse le samedi
soir à cette heure là un téléfilm
américain ce soir visage de tueurs je
vous le dis monsieur mougeotte
je te le dis etienne c'est pas sympa ça
[Musique]
si le jeu si le jeu c'est de diffuser
des séries américaines tout le monde
peut le faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans la série les envahisseurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
avec wright qui naissent dans le rôle de
david vincent
diane bérard oui je sais président oui
je sais service public lui le service
public je sais où
oui pas de séries américaines à par
deezer stone les vestes europe hockey et
des séries françaises avec isner non ok
politique
oui thierry je comprends la réaction de
la chaîne assez normal ya là un problème
de déontologie avons déjà peut-être une
autre solution vous savez plutôt que
d'essayer d'attirer la clientèle est
chez nous sur cette chaîne
on peut peut-être tout simplement la
décourager d'aller sur l'autre chaîne et
en faisant quoi bein peut-être en leur
racontant la fin de la série en question
a pas mal vous la connaissez
avec bien entendu mesdames messieurs
doit bien sûr je vais vous raconter la
fin du téléfilm visage de tueurs qui
passe en ce moment sur tf1 celui que
l'on prend pour l'assassin le jeune
policier n'est en fait qu'un pigeon et
locales wii est le commanditaire de
l'assassinât est autre que le chef de la
police à la fin deux visages de tueurs
en ce moment sur tf1
le gentil professeur dé ce cas là dessus
le chef de la police après une course
poursuite sur la façade du building
voilà donc vous pouvez rester sur france
2 puisque vous connaissez la fin du
téléfilm de tf1
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linda hardy tube abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu